domestic flights are about to get
cheaper
the chancellor has cut air passenger
duty a long planned move to bring taxes
on internal flights into line with
international ones
but for some it was a surprising
decision just days ahead of the crucial
cop 26 u.n climate summit being hosted
in glasgow there was an enormous
climate-shaped hole in the heart of this
budget and it was really very very
disappointing to see the few measures
that were there were actually going in
the wrong direction in other words
making car driving cheaper making short
haul flights cheaper so this was a
massively wasted opportunity and i think
demonstrates ahead of this climate
summit that this government is simply
not serious about showing any kind of
climate leadership
passengers at glasgow airport will be
saving six pounds fifty per flight think
differently i'm waiting for
my son to arrive with my granddaughter
so i quite
enjoy the fact that it's going to be a
little bit cheaper i'd love to travel
from london to glasgow on a on a train
but it does take
well it takes a day rather than an hour
for some airline managers struggling
with the effects of covid on travel the
tax cut is a welcome one what i think
this cut will do is to support a number
of routes particularly those around the
periphery of the united kingdom which
are facing increasing economic
challenges
although the government's net zero
carbon emissions strategy didn't feature
prominently in the budget the chancellor
has increased taxes on long-haul flights
over five and a half thousand miles
perhaps providing some balance
in many ways this is less about the
detail of counting the carbon emissions
than it is about the optics about the
message the uk government is sending to
the world about the sacrifices it is and
is not willing to make in the race to go
green
the glasgow summit is looming and the
deliberate choice to make some carbon
intensive transport cheaper will lead
many to question the climate credibility
of the uk at the very moment it is
trying to be a global leader
hannah thomas peter sky news